NASIR KHAN: Hi, and welcome
to Google Developers Live.
My name is Nasir Khan, and
I work for Google Wallet.
We are going to talk
about Orbitz today.
Orbitz is one of our
premiere partners.
We have done integration
with Google Wallet APIs,
and we're going to go into
more detail about what
they have done.
This is actually a
two-part segment,
so today, we're going to
focus on the Instant Buy APIs,
whereas in the
following segment,
we're going to talk about
Wallet Objects API, which
relates to Office.
So first of all,
let me welcome Brian
who's joining us from Orbitz.
Brian, are you there?
BRIAN LEE: Yeah.
Hi.
NASIR KHAN: Hi.
How are you doing today?
BRIAN LEE: I'm doing good.
Very excited about
this opportunity
to share my experience
on the Instant Buy API.
How are you doing?
NASIR KHAN: I'm very well, thank
you, and thanks for joining us.
So the Android
app that you built
and that you included
Instant Buy API with it,
can you tell us a
little bit about what
it does, what the
users can do with it,
and what essentially
does it offer overall?
BRIAN LEE: Sure.
Our Orbitz app is the most
full-featured travel booking
app available on Android today.
Not only can you search
and book hotels, flights,
and rental cars, you can also
access your booked itineraries,
including the ones you
booked on the website.
You can also join our new
Orbits Rewards Loyalty Program
directly from our app,
and start earning rewards
for your booking
flights, hotels,
and use it instantly on hotels.
And now with Google
Wallet Instant Buy,
it's even easier to
use our app to take
advantage of these great offers.
NASIR KHAN: Great, great.
So for users who are not
familiar with Instant Buyer,
I would recommend them to
look at a previous recording,
previous videos,
but in a nutshell,
it's basically a payment
API, which integrators
can use in their Android app.
And the way it works
is that it makes
it really simple for the
users to access their Google
Wallet from within the native
app and use it for payments.
So we're going to see some
examples of this going forward,
but essentially, it streamlines
the process of payments
to just about two
or three clicks
versus a more cumbersome
entry process where users have
to enter their credit
card information
and things of that kind.
So I believe you can show
us the app live, Brian.
Can you?
BRIAN LEE: Yes, I can.
NASIR KHAN: All right.
So let's switch to
the app right away.
Let's see what happens here.
So we can see a screen now.
Are you ready to demo?
BRIAN LEE: Sure.
Let's do a simple search
for a hotel in Chicago.
So we'll click Hotel to search
it, and for the destination,
we'll type Chicago.
Select Chicago, and select
the dates, and click Search.
So we'll just select the first
hotel, make sure we like it,
and select a room.
So when you're in the booking
screen as you can see,
there's a lot of
information to populate
if it's your first time booking,
information like your name,
email, credit card info,
and billing address.
So instead of filling
everything in,
let's see what
happens when we click
the Buy with Google button.
So just like that, you
have a list of credit cards
you have linked in
your Google Wallet,
and you can set it as a
default payment method as well.
What's interesting
to note here is
that this dialogue
and everything in it
is actually all
part of Wallet API.
I didn't have to make any of
this dialogue or the content
inside.
And in fact, the
Orbitz app doesn't even
have access to this
list of credit cards.
All I had to do was create
a masked wallet request
with the purchase amount and
send it using the Google Wallet
API, which makes it really
simple for me as a developer.
So now that we have
this, we'll select a card
and click Continue
and see what happens.
So now you can see that
the billing information
is updated with your
Google Wallet email
address and your funding
card information.
Our Orbitz have never
received the full credit card
information you have
stored in Google Wallet.
We just get and show the credit
card type and the last four
digits of the funding
card for user reference.
And this is basically what the
masked wallet object is, see it
at the travel
information, it's all
pre-populated with
the information
from the masked wallet.
And just like that, with
just a single click,
you're ready to check out.
And since we have a promotion
for using Google on Instant
Buy right now, let's just
make sure to get that discount
as well.
So now when you're ready
and when you click the Agree
and Book button, this is when
we actually make the full wallet
request, we add a
Google Wallet API.
And what this essentially
does is get a single use
virtual proxy card
information, which basically
gets passed on to
our Orbitz back end
to be processed for payment.
NASIR KHAN: Perfect.
Thank you so much
for the demo, Brian.
So as Brian was telling
that there are essentially
two steps and just
kind of recap that.
There is this masked wallet,
which essentially happens
when the users click
on the Buy with Google
button for the first time.
This is the first interaction
of the users with Google Wallet,
and what they get back is
this masked information,
which Brian was showing on the
screen, which has the user's
address also the last four
digits of their banking card.
And then when the
user confirm it,
that's when a full
wallet request
was made from within
the app, which
gets the proxy card, which
is a one-time used card, not
the card that the users
have in their wallet,
but a proxy to
that, which can then
be used from within the app
to actually make the purchase
or make the charge on it.
And so there is a two-step
very simple API, first
with the masked wallet
request and then
you do a full wallet request.
And in the response,
you get what
you need, which is
basically a proxy card,
which you can then charge.
So the benefit of
this approach is
that once you have filled
out say a credit card
processing from within the
app, you're accepting users,
entering their credit card,
you're pretty much set up
to use Google Wallet Instant
Buy because you can use
the same rails, you'll
use the proxy card almost
as if the user had typed
in their credit card,
and then you use it to
process the charge if you're
doing the credit card process.
So the idea behind this
approach was to the limit
the integration effort the
developers are allowed to do,
not only in the front end, but
also in the back end, which
is probably more significant
because then they don't have
to really integrate
anything in the back end.
So let me ask you, Brian,
what I just mentioned.
Did you experience
the same thing?
Did you feel that it
was an easy integration,
or what are your general
thoughts about integration
experience?
BRIAN LEE: As far as integration
was, the happy paths where
you just had to implement a very
simple use case on the Android
apps, that was really
straightforward.
NASIR KHAN: Right.
At least, the hope
that we had when
we developed this API
was to limit the back end
changes altogether.
So is that something
that you also
saw or did you have to make
any changes on your back end?
BRIAN LEE: Right.
Payment processing change
usually is not really
a simple change,
but in this case,
the proxy card could be almost
treated as like a credit card.
So we had to do some
additional changes
to support a Google Wallet that
it's actually a Google Wallet,
but as far as the
actual process goes,
it's very just quite similar to
a regular credit card payment.
NASIR KHAN: And if--
let me ask you this,
Brian-- how long did it
actually take from start
to finish in terms
of integrating
Instant Buy in your app?
BRIAN LEE: Well the very simple
happy paths just doing the Buy
with Google and getting
the aperture proxy card,
and it was actually without
any error case handling
took maybe a day or two.
That was really straightforward.
In addition to that, we had
to do some back end changes,
and we also had to do so
edge-case handling and a lot
of testing, so the
whole process took
about a few weeks, two
to three weeks about,
three to four weeks,
depending on how
you look at [INAUDIBLE] process.
But actually it wasn't
that bad at all.
NASIR KHAN: Yeah.
That's pretty good, actually.
I mean, if you think
about [INAUDIBLE]
it's a pretty big
app, and in terms
of getting it live in two to
three weeks with a new API,
that's pretty good.
So in terms of getting
the app on the Play Store
and getting people to use
it, are you seeing people
now using Instant Buy more,
and do you have any feedback?
I think it's very
early days, but do you
have any feedback from users?
If they're finding
it easy to deal
with Instant Buy versus
filling out the forms manually?
BRIAN LEE: I'm sorry.
I missed the last
part of the question.
NASIR KHAN: So I was saying,
it's pretty early days,
but do you have
any user feedback
in terms of how the
experience has been using
Instant Buy versus filling
out the forms manually?
BRIAN LEE: Oh, actually
when we started
the Instant Buy integration,
we were actually having reviews
that people wished that
we had the Google Instant
Buy integration,
so it was great.
After we integrated it, we could
reply to the user that hey,
we actually have this Instant
Buy all and pre-populate
the forms as a really
positive experience.
NASIR KHAN: Fantastic.
Thank you, Brian.
Thanks for your time today, and
don't forget to tune in again
for the second
segment of our video
in which we are going to talk
about the Wallet Objects API.
Thank you.